Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis Luciano, argentin d’origine.
J’aurais adoré venir vous parler de foot,
cependant, mon expertise,
c’est la bio-impression 3D.
C’est quoi la bio-impression 3D ?
Cela consiste à fabriquer
des tissus et des organes
avec une imprimante 3D.
Non, non, je ne suis pas fou,
je suis simplement
un chirurgien et un chercheur
qui vient vous expliquer
comment c’est possible.
Deux rencontres m’ont guidé
vers cette expertise.
La première, c'était avec mon professeur
de chirurgie en 2002.
Celui-ci avait comme spécialité
la reconstruction d’oreille.
C’est un organe très complexe, l’oreille.
Rien que l’oreille externe se compose
de huit parties et deux cartilages.
Je me suis posé la question :
« Comment pouvons-nous
fabriquer des oreilles ? »
La deuxième rencontre, je me dirigeais
vers la piscine d’un super hôtel
quand j’ai croisé un collègue
qui me donne un magazine.
Je n’ai jamais rejoint la piscine
parce que j’étais fasciné
par un article scientifique
qui expliquait comment nous pouvions
utiliser les cellules graisseuses
pour fabriquer un os.
Ces deux rencontres allaient marquer
ma vie comme chercheur
dans le monde de la bio-impression 3D.
Notre corps est une merveilleuse machine
qui s’autorépare naturellement.
Vous tombez, vous vous brûlez
et votre corps va engager
un processus de cicatrisation.
Mais comme toute machine,
elle a ses limites.
Par exemple, nous n’avons pas la capacité,
comme le lézard,
qui, quand il perd sa queue,
on sait tous que ça reconstruit.
On appelle ça l’auto-régénération
des membres.
Si la brûlure est trop profonde
ou si un de vos organes dysfonctionne,
alors là, votre machine a besoin
d’un coup de main extérieur.
Et c’est là tout l’objet
de la médecine régénératrice.
La première greffe d’organe
a été réalisée en 1950.
À l’époque,
c’était un mythe qui devenait réalité.
Cet événement vraiment a modifié,
changé, la pratique de la médecine,
et fait naître aussi
les besoins des dons d’organes.
Les progrès scientifiques sont magnifiques
et nous accompagnent.
Les champs de recherche sont prometteurs,
mais quand on évoque
les besoins des dons d’organes,
et le nombre de donneurs,
c’est la catastrophe.
En France, 20 000 personnes en attente
pour 6 000 transplantations chaque année.
Soit une moyenne de plus de trois années
d’attente pour une transplantation.
Le temps de mourir plusieurs fois.
Avec mes équipes, je consacre
une grande partie de mon temps
à tenter d’imprimer des tissus
et des organes vitaux
comme la peau, le cœur,
les vaisseaux sanguins, l’intestin.
Aujourd’hui, c’est une réalité.
Nous pouvons imprimer des tissus
dans les laboratoires
pour remplacer les tissus endommagés.
On appelle ça l'ingénierie tissulaire.
L'ingénierie tissulaire fait partie
de la médecine régénératrice.
Cette médecine travaille sur
la régénération des cellules, bien sûr,
dans l’impression des tissus
comme les muscles
et aussi pour la création des organes
vitaux comme la peau et le cœur
grâce à la bio-impression 3D.
Avec cette technologie,
nous avons besoin des deux éléments
pour fabriquer nos organes :
une encre bio-compatible,
comme le collagène,
et les cellules saines d’un patient.
L’association de ces deux éléments
va permettre justement
d’éradiquer les risques de rejet.
Jusqu’ici,
on a créé notre première feuille de tissu,
notre première couche cellulaire.
Cette perspective est fascinante.
Mais comme je viens de le dire,
ce n’est que la 1e couche.
Pour faire la peau,
il me faut dix couches.
Pour faire un cœur,
plus de deux cents couches.
Donc c’est là l’objectif
d’utiliser l’imprimante 3D
pour imprimer tel un mille-feuilles
de couches cellulaires
jusqu’à ce que mon organe devienne solide.
Vous imaginez l’immensité
des possibilités !
Prenons l’exemple d’un grand brûlé.
Actuellement, nous travaillons
pour imprimer directement
sur la blessure du patient
en étant guidé par un scan
au cœur de la salle d’opération.
D’ici à cinq ans,
la réparation anatomique sera
au format exact de la plaie,
sans nécessité
d’une greffe complémentaire.
Ces pratiques révolutionnaires
et innovantes
comportent trois facteurs clés.
Le premier facteur, c’est notre matériau,
notre encre qu’on appelle un bio-matériau,
qui permet l’organisation des cellules
et le support de ces cellules.
Comme les algues marines bretonnes.
Le deuxième facteur, ce sont les cellules.
Pour imprimer les tissus et imaginez-vous
pour imprimer des organes,
on a besoin de millions et de millions
et de millions de cellules.
Donc l’objectif primordial,
c’est justement d’amplifier
la quantité de cellules nécessaires
à partir d’une petite pastille
d’un tissu ou d’un organe.
Le troisième facteur, le plus important,
et cette phase-là,
c’est la plus complexe,
c’est : comment allons-nous donner vie
à ces impressions ?
Donner vie en science,
c’est faire en sorte
que les organes puissent traiter l’oxygène
et les nutriments nécessaires
à son développement.
Nos organes présentent un réseau
de vaisseaux sanguins interconnectés
afin d’être complètement
vascularisés et oxygénés.
Il ne suffit pas seulement
de bio-imprimer les tissus,
mais oui, de les rendre fonctionnels.
Et pour cela, l’interconnexion entre
les millions de cellules est fondamentale.
Nous sommes nombreux dans le monde
à travailler sur ces recherches.
Le sujet
est très complexe.
Tout va très vite.
Cela ne sera pas facile.
Aujourd'hui, j'imprime des tissus.
Et je suis convaincu que d’ici à cinq ans,
nous saurons imprimer la peau
avec sa sensibilité et sa fonctionnalité.
Et d’ici à dix ans,
nous pourrons transplanter
des organes bio-imprimés
directement dans la salle de chirurgie.
Et pour moi,
c’est extrêmement motivant,
tous les jours,
de me dire : « Mon futur,
c’est d’imprimer notre futur. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)